are you doing me now but just checking
that with me
right okay
let me get this something
good
okay good morning everybody um nice to
see you all including bill pennington
um
yeah i look at the morning chair and i
would love to see myself
yeah right okay we have you know we've
lost simon but we've got rachel okay
i'm here instead of uh
oh
yeah exactly
okay
apologies karen uh we've had apologies
from councillor inch and councillor
cotton hunting chair okay
five minutes for the last meeting
um
this is the last meeting that
channelly shared
so page three
four
five
and
six um
that was proposing please
secondly
and
actually
good
okay
all those in favor
[Music]
okay
okay we're going to the action listen up
page seven
to ten
[Music]
number 176
that looks as though it's complete
177
[Music]
stacy that's ongoing
[Music]
well chad
[Music]
i can probably deal with that now um
would you like to
if you'd like me just uh then we
effectively no one is affected by the
housing
benefit that love because we back date
the claims from the date that they've
actually received although i am pleased
to report that backlog has reduced quite
substantially as well so we are we are
getting there i think we're down from
380 pieces of outstanding work to 210 so
from last month so we're really making
moves there
thanks for that stacy
um
should we shall we close that then and
say complete
yes
yeah proposal
mr aims secondary
rachel
all those in favor then we close that
okay
that's all levels
188
qbr questions and answer details of
switchboard to be included in the
members bulletin that was done so that's
complete
um
eight one eight
qbr
questions
a nice long
thing there from
richard
and that is now complete
that's it okay
move on
public contributions but nothing we've
got no public killing
declarations of interest you all
understand about the declaration of
input
agent matters brought forward with the
information of the chair well i've got
no urgent matters you've got anything
stephen now and i think so
the gender
agreement of agenda items part one and
two well we've got no part two
qbl one financial pages only 11-15
and the reason
basically we've only got the financial
pages is that chris is ill normally
just as far as he's ill and i don't know
what situation he wouldn't jump in
you don't know
okay
next week so they worked out what we
need to do in terms of bringing that
detail back to
industry big medium
okay so this is a bit of a long term
numbers
okay
okay very nicely
okay
[Music]
i think you have to speak right into it
all right
um
um
for once i haven't actually got um
that's a little slideshow so just
actually my words
um
in front of you i'll get to the headline
there you go straight from the back so
to speak
the headline figure is after the first
three months of this financial year
we're forecasting a deficit against
budget for over 1 million pounds
and when you take into canada we're only
balancing the budget by taking 373 000
pounds out of the reserve by the
transitioning government of reserve so
the ballot will put it into
huge reserves to balance the actual
difference between the forecast
increments spending for the year is 1.4
million 1.45 million pounds
given that our growth suspended in the
region of 15 million ignoring held in
benefits subsidy payments
housing payments that's about seven
percent of our growth turnover so that's
the scale of the issue that we're facing
and there's kind of two factors at play
i'd say one factor
is inflation and the other factor is the
housing crisis that we face which has an
inflationary component to it
so i'll go on to the
homelessness of the temple accommodation
in the very first instance
in the first three months of this
financial year we have spent more on
temporary accommodation than we spent in
the whole than each of the previous
pre-financial years so in 2019 20 2019
20 21 and 21-22 we spent less than three
hundred thousand pounds on temporary
accommodation we've already spent that
figure in the first three months of this
year
the reasons are detailed in the report
but this is meeting our statutory
obligation
for residents of today at risk of
homelessness
so we're actually broadcasting for the
year
and overspend against budget of 890 000
pounds we actually budget the
homelessness in terms of accommodation
to cost this money that's actually how
much older budgets it is
and the main reason we we cannot find
sustainable long-term tenancies for our
residents
uh when we're looking at lots of
difficulties only yesterday c and r
approved the conversion of four survival
storm rolling up it's hostile
combination as a measure which may
alleviate
somewhat this
issue that was based
the next reason we're forecasting such a
dramatic overspend is inflation
uh so i've listed
a couple of things in the report well
first off i'll go on to stat cost which
is already out of date since i wrote the
report so latest today we got the detail
of the employer's offer to the unions
and it is a flat increase on every pay
scale 1
925 pounds each
at each pay scale so every individual
will will get
1925 pounds increase obviously pro
writing if they're part-time
so given that
um a lot of our staff are towards the
bottom of the scope with any
organization there's a hierarchy so
there's more staff at the lower end than
the right at the top
that weighs to about seven percent
increase on our pay bill and we only
budgeted for two percent
perhaps an additional cost of 495.000
[Music]
financial years
we've obviously everybody here in this
room will know that utility and fuel
prices have gone on
the council isn't somehow magically
insulated from those pressures
the tourists listening up on the gas
electric we were in a pre-paid fixed
price deal which expires at the end of
september so it's
mitigated it somewhat this year
but
fuel is and utilities are expected to
always spend about 120 2089 000 respects
but the utility overspend is as i said
is somewhat artificially low this year
because of the pre-purchase deal that we
were a member of
one of the rare
good news stories
it's interesting the interest rates have
risen we get more money from the money
that we put on central deposits
so
the issue we have of course we've got an
overspend we do have a what's called the
transition government funding reserve
our building society account
but based on the projections in the
report which are now going to be worse
because of the pay award
we're going to use 61 percent of that
transition in government funding reserve
meeting the deficit
quite clearly
that without any remedial action will be
exhausted sometime during 23 24.
um within the report i've not
mentioned issues of recruitment and
retention the council's experience
really using recruiting and retaining
staff
we have a vacancy target the 400 000
pounds so if i was to leave tomorrow it
would be a recruitment process and
there'll be a period of time
um where my calls would be vacant and
maybe something to be acting up but
they're positively vacant so there'd be
some saving according to the council
we've got a target four hundred thousand
pounds based on the vacancies we've
already incurred during this year and
making assumptions about when those
votes will be filled with or in the
target which you might think is a good
news but i don't believe it says because
that means it's pressured on council
departments in terms of the delivery of
services
so the projected figures you've got
there
don't include new vacancies which will
occur and any assumption about when they
were built
so
um i think all the things the reports
has been noting and notices that there
have been some members from i think with
mr dan gates which have been answered
happy to take any questions at this
juncture
and then the secret to ask any questions
over and above the questions that have
already been submitted prior to the
meeting
any questions over and above the
questions that we've already pulled
in
anybody hey
are we going through the qbr thing
sorry
are we going through the qpr
is that right now
yes have you got anything else
that is not on there that you would like
to have
[Music]
sorry no no
so it is the cost of our economic
development team
and really set a cycle but what i'm
saying is economic
answering the question
is from i think with mr harkins today
both that's kind of very similar
questions if you're honest
what is discretionary spend in the
council what's your status back economic
regeneration is not a statutory
expenditure of the council so i've
listed there the budget
of the economic regeneration function
agency sorry
oh no that isn't crystal enough sorry
apologies for the no
also the state's manager we
we're still looking for another way out
there we are
any other we'll go we'll go into the
questions and answer them
okay i was sorry i was just going to
talk about um i think there's something
here about solar um you haven't
responded to a question for mr harper
um
we'll
[Music]
[Music]
well
[Music]
i was commenting on an answer to mr
hayes about solar power
am i allowed to do
i'm commenting on a response to mr hayes
mr harper's question about solar panels
i was wanting to ask followed on
what page is that one that's on page
three of the qbr
is
[Music]
he's on page three of the supplement um
with questions and answers but i think
you'll start on page
[Music]
yeah we haven't gone through page two
right
first first question on here is from
council phil pennington are you happy
with the answer yeah i am impressed with
the answer if i i believe that's a
better rate than last year given the
economic situation you're in so i
congratulate the team for
their their collection rates
yeah but i think that's a better
collection rate than the previous year
do you want to answer that
and yeah actually it's not my team of
courses okay
well that's that's very that's very nice
of you to say that
um staff question from uh mr harper
what is the actual cost this year for
agency staff
um ian with
an answer are you happy yeah it's
obviously we're going to run out of
money before the end of the year yeah
don't look good
um
how much do the pv units contribute to
any statement is there any other plans
to reduce cost
answer
the answer is are you happy with the
answer
yes i just all i'm wondering as well is
that so we're now reducing the
electricity
what are we doing about the uh lectures
to produce over the weekend when
nobody's in the offices
right okay
all right
thank you
don't you get sold back to the national
grid
yeah that's fine
that's right
is this a question that you would want
to ask something about peter i don't
know where we are sorry which question
well look on page three factory speak
three agenda item eight
yeah page three yeah so from the top
there yeah on page three power question
from mr harvey yeah that was the one i
was going to ask right well ian's happy
with the answer to that
i know we get 3.8
3 800
revenue from the solar panels and the
council building is that right it says
here yeah i'm just wondering
i was wondering if david ace wanted to
comment on the possibilities of the
income generation from other solar
installations given the extreme
financial
like we are in council
it's outside of my area specialist to be
truthful i don't know how economic that
would be well i mean i just look at that
that's three thousand eight hundred
pounds and that's from riverbank
passed out and that's what we got last
year that's all we've got i mean so i
don't know what the capital investment
was for that but i don't that i don't
want to have to
that's the ceiling isn't going to bridge
the gap no i mean in terms of revenue
generation would one we consider
actually using the capital outlay
ordering whatever to produce that
presumably very quick revenue response
i would want to detail that i would not
i would no i have no input or no insight
into whether
to i can't think of another building
that we can put the solar panels on
given that i think they're on this
building and i think they're on river
bank i don't know whatever council
premises we could put them on and maybe
one of the
um
leisure centers i could only think of
the top in the head
i wouldn't know how much that would cost
to invest and i don't know what the
return would bring
do you want to answer anything to do
with that
it's
sorry yeah
even
it's it's something that i guess
activators will look at in terms of its
budget and business plan obviously then
it has to be recommendation back to
torridge and because the authorities
build this person to be included in
the
the pitch and the capital program but
that would come later this year so the
initial phase is the uh marketplace to
bring it forward back in his business
plan uh back to volcano in october
so any things around looking at um
obviously the heating and the swimming
pools and everything else uh would be
some consideration but actually quite
right right we pointed out people on
council games there are a couple of
investment needs and our capital program
is already overspent
uh so he would be taking something else
out of the capital program uh to put
this in
well yeah it could be uh obviously a
payback in terms of uh costs later on
yeah i mean the revenue possibilities
are quite significant and it will
contribute to our green agenda and
climate agenda as well
okay we can then
okay we'll move on to the next question
section 215 question from mr harper once
again a budget of 110
okay is shown not spending previous
years well if we spend the [ __ ] david i
think the answer is enough i think it is
are you happy with that answer
yeah
okay financial year 2022 23 questions
from
mr harper and derelict a deficit
1.454 million is broadcast this year
what would the cost to tdc be if it
should purely provided statutory
services that are required
and you wrote all that down there david
which um i consider one to totally
understand happy with the answer
the answer yes i'm happy with the answer
well
but at this point i think the trouble is
we've got some difficult decisions to
make in the future yeah um because at
the end of the day
clearly we tried for another large
number of years to try and generate more
income from the council
um
and when you look at one point four or
five million i think i'd like to set up
a business statute it's that sort of
money in one year
party member budget working home uh
which is already meeting on a three
weekly basis
uh looking at different options for
either increased income or reduced
expenditure
we're proposing that's the september
full council meeting uh the day that we
presented a further update on the
updates on the updates of the uh the
budget protection and
financial strategy that at that point uh
we can bring hopefully bring forward uh
some of the
thoughts considerations and hopefully
recommendations from that working group
uh members to consider to start
making some inroads into the budget
downstairs
okay
uh we'll move on to the next one here
well you can see the list there you know
what we plot out to
all the places other places
et cetera it's actually including the
cav
um okay we'll move on to sure sorry
sorry
let me just clarify the
payment rnli in that list yeah that's
for the lifeguards at westwood homes
without that you don't get the blue
black status of west virginia
right
[Music]
david has come back with with an answer
are you happy with the answer
i'm very happy with the answer yeah but
that's it i've seen him coming here
because it's answered more than more
than questions
um i guess to me it's an observation
that the head room
that we might have had between
statutory
discretionary budget
is narrowing
to the point that the headroom
um
spending 22 23 what element is mixed
statutory and discretionary
uh you've had that answer happy with
that answer yes
number three
um what financial instruments are
available to the council to enable us to
maintain a balanced budget
should adverse conditions like exhaust
transition in government funding reserve
happy with that
answer
he answers the question why don't he
answer the question well i'm not happy
with it i mean he took me today to be
happy i mean
[Music]
i don't know
i think a lot of counselors are going to
be unhappy surely
um
lost it
what is the estimated timeline for
members budget working group to report
back to the
[Music]
okay there was a folder on um
the
meters to the cables i haven't seen
anything
where they're going to be anything
that's going on before the council there
is a folder on the drive
okay so that's the end of the question
questions
sorry yes yes sorry
um
just to clarify what daley was saying
so full council on the 5th of september
is it
will there be a report from
there'll be two reports
so the first report will be report that
i do for section 151 officer and that
will update members on the financial
position of the council vote for this
year and in the years going forward to
the best of my ability there'll be a
report from the member budget working
group not reports in my name but with
the member budget working group with the
proposals which have come out of that
group's deliberations over the last few
months so my report will go first to set
the scene so members know the scale of
where we are and the issues we face and
then we report back from the members
budget working group
um
statues to present that report but it'd
be from the member budget working until
what would report my name would be
in the name of that group yeah
do you you may not know this now yet i
don't know will there be recommendations
attached to that before i will
and will decide
at that meeting ideally so
right okay thank
to 2021 initial results john i'm sorry
[Music]
good morning
[Music]
so
yeah these are the census results um
from 2021
they're the initial results that have
been released
they were released on the 28th of june
so there were a few weeks um
they're not as uh detailed as i was
expecting
this was the first
or the biggest online
census that we had and i kind of was
expecting a lot more results
what i've got in front of you today are
the top level
results
from the census which shows that
district level only so they don't go
down below toward level we're hoping for
some more results
being released throughout the year
starting from october so i should be
able to provide you with some more
information as as we get them
but this is the initial results that's
that's come from the census
so
center stay as a reminder to everybody
was the 21st of march so that was the
day when they took all the stats from
and
the
account
for england and wales was 59 million
597 000 people
that's the largest population ever
recorded through a census so that's kind
of where we're at
the england and wales
population grew by 3.5 million that's a
6.3
uh increase i'll show how that reflects
on college in a little bit
the highest
population growth was
east of england and that increased by
8.3
there was
30 million 420 thousand 100 women in the
census that's 51
and uh 49
men
[Music]
we've got more
people
or more people than ever before in older
age range and i'll show you a few uh
graphs in a minute
and those age 65 and over was 18.6
and that's quite an increase on 2011.
there are 24 million 782 800 households
um and that's an increase of more than
1.4 million since 2011 which again is a
6.1 increase
that this graph here just shows you um
kind of
since the census began in 1801 kind of
the the growth
through um through the year through the
10-year
[Music]
periods
with one gap
due to the second world war in 1941
so this shows um the populist population
changes um from the regions
so as i mentioned earlier the east of
england was the biggest
uh 8.3
but the next biggest was the southwest
obviously you know where we are and that
was 7.8
[Music]
so what did that mean for torridge well
the population size in torridge
increased by six point seven percent
so that that was from sixty three
thousand eight hundred in 2011 to sixty
eight thousand one hundred and twenty
twenty one
so that's a higher than average increase
so six point six percent
um
which is higher than um
six point six percent was the english uh
increase and uh ours was bigger than
that
so where did we fit with the rest of the
southwest well
[Music]
cornwall had an increase of 7.1
on west 6.6
[Music]
3
was the biggest
at 15.8
and e7 had 13.8
so our 6.7
increase
was slightly
lower than the
average of the southwest
so as i mentioned earlier there were
more people than ever age 65 years and
over and i'll show you in a minute how
that reflects on torridge
um
it does show that the population is
continuing to age
we've got more than one in six now 18.4
we're aged 65 and over on census day
this is the highest percentage ever
so overall in england there has been an
increase of 20.1 percent in people aged
65 and over
an increase of 3.6
people aged 15 to 64 and an increase of
5
in children so i'll just show you
this this kind of shows you um
how that works uh in torridge as well
compared to the increases um in in
england
now
um
the top kind of circle there that that
i've highlighted that shows our aging
population
that's something that we we kind of knew
about we know that we've got issues with
that in this area and how that affects
our service delivery and and everything
that we do
[Music]
um the the the red kind of circle
highlighted there
that's kind of what we've highlighted
before about the grain drain
that's kind of the the um
the age working age group and
slightly below kind of leaving the area
and that's quite an interesting one
and i guess the other thing to say is
this took place during kobe
so there were some kind of quite big
differences
um
particularly around london area where
they came out of the um some of the
suburbs
to to here
to the rural areas but you also we still
have that kind of brain drain which is
quite an interesting one
and there you'll see that i said we had
a
decrease in people aged 15 to 64.
but we had a 30
increase in people aged over 65.
so that's quite an interesting bit you
know we have information ready for kind
of how we need to
serve our population going forward
sure
yes
guys
the term brain drain yeah is
a little bit concerning for that age
group that remains in the area
i just wondered if we could not use
another term for those that remain
within the area because it doesn't like
um certain connotations
it's just a common term uh counselor
we're more than happy to use a different
given term i know we used it 10 years
ago when we are
showing kind of similar statistics so
more than happy to use a different term
thank you
very much yeah
um so what this graph shows is that of
the third there's only 32 of the 309
local authorities um
that have over 30
increase of those age 65 and over and as
you see there torridge is one of those
32 and it's just interesting where the
spread is um
[Music]
yeah i just thought it was quite an
interesting little um uh graphic there
there's something around the kingdom yes
yeah yeah there wasn't anything that
really jumped out at me at that time
there will be some more detailed um
investigations into this but at the
moment you know it was just a bit of a
highlight
so this this slide just shows the
population density so people per square
kilometer
so there were 434 residents per square
meter in england in 2021 that's up from
the 407
per square meter in 2011
but
back kennedy tech sorry yeah
but as you'll see for torridge um in
2011 we were 65 people per square
kilometer and that's been increased to
69 people per square kilometer 6.2
percent
increase
and what we're seeing there is uh
torridge is the second least densely
populated of the 30 southwest local
authority areas
this one just shows a number of
households
so
we've increased by nine percent the
number of households from just under 28
000 in 2011 to 30 500 in 2021
um and it does go on to say um
only 12 local authorities experienced
the drop in the number of households
between 20 and 21
so and that go
well i mentioned earlier about
kensington and chelsea and westminster
which people kind of leave in the cities
uh during clothing
so i'm afraid i don't have any further
stats at the moment they haven't
released those down to um ward level
they haven't released the information
about
[Music]
talking to mr harper earlier about
education and payments and things like
that
we are expecting some more releases um
in october and then they have said that
they will issue some more uh through to
the end of october and end of the year
and and onwards but we're hoping that
the list there that i've given you will
be the first
list with more details in october
i'm happy to answer any questions but i
thought it's just a quick overview as
you guys do use
statistics and everything for them qpr
and monitoring performance and
that going forward
but if you have anything for me i'm
happy to answer but as i say we are very
limited of what has been released at
this time
any questions for john
phil pennington yes sorry interesting to
take quite a number of households 3 000
households up from 2011 to 2021
that's um 300 households a year
how many houses are rebuilding every
year in college
[Music]
i'm afraid i can answer you that one
one of my um i haven't under 10 year
check but i said yes it's less than 150.
so no wonder we're seeing
such uh huge pressures on rent and
health writing
that's why we need to build out
you know actually encourage us to bring
the prices back and build more houses
anyway any more questions
for john
no
okay we'll move on thank you
i think we've got to sit there
again
digital by default
16-27 john
um
thank you
this committee agreed the last um
digital by default strategy
and i'm sure you'll all remember that
was on the 8th of august 2017
from the report
from steve
yeah
terrific
so yeah it was time it was time for for
an update um a refresh
things have obviously changed um
[Music]
particularly because of covid that's
speeded up um
are kind of digital um by default kind
of workings and how people
uh and individuals
now
operate with their banks with their
building societies with their shopping
so it was time to
kind of develop a new strategy
it's our framework for continuing our
digital transformation it's something
that um you know all organizations are
doing
as i mentioned colbit has accelerated
the use of information technologies more
and more people are shopping online more
people are banking online
um so this is what this uh digital by
default strategy is doing is
getting us in a position where uh we
we've got their technologies and uh
infrastructure uh ready to ready to
to keep keep that moving forward uh
helping us modernize
we also need to
realize that not everybody
is on that same digital
experience so we still need to provide
services
and contact
that is not available
digitally and that is covered a little
bit in here as well
so
i won't go through page by page but um
it is there hopefully you've had a
chance to have a look
we've um
we're looking at it so that we can keep
pace with how things are changing
outside of the council and and with our
own personal lives
um we need them to keep up with the
cloud technology we need to keep up with
um how people um want to access our
services 24 hours a day seven days a
week
that also means we need to look at the
security side of things we need to make
sure that that we're keeping ahead of
that because the hackers and everything
are getting more sophisticated you'll
see information from time to time in the
members bulletin
and members um
would also have uh
had other notice that other counsellors
have
[Music]
experienced um
pretend hacking and stuff like that so
you know it's stuff that we've all got
to keep ahead of it's uh it's our kind
of a basis for the way forward um you
know we'll be looking at digital skills
as well from the workforce the
counselors and everything moving forward
so
this is our framework it's uh keep us
going for
some actions in that for the next few
years
um and it will give us something that we
can kind of move forward with i'm more
than happy to answer any questions um i
don't intend to go through it
pay to our page and if you want me to
check
anybody got any questions
steve
no thanks
um
i guess the question always is access
you know people
technology
yeah i know there are kind of other
public bodies if you say like uh
libraries and that kind of doing that
type of um
help i suppose we've also got in our
reception area we've got
kind of a terminal on that that we can
help
and we're still
[Music]
having people coming to reception we're
still taking their phone calls and we're
doing all of that and if if there's uh
information online or there's online
forms and our customer service team will
actually go through the form for them
online if we can't do it so you know we
are trying to do it there are some other
ones like the citizens advice now doing
some training uh and things like that so
it's you know keeping an eye on on that
that's out there and i think this
my mum's 19. she's on facebook there and
i'm not and it's like you know she's
helping me with that so i think i think
that that kind of divide is getting less
but we still need to keep keep keeping
rest of it for sure
didn't lock down and kobe pick up the
problem of a lot of low income families
not being able to access the internet
because of the affordability of
ipads and things
i've not seen any statistics on that
we've always been um wary of social
exclusion through kind of affordability
and that type of
kind of issues going forward um
what we have noticed is that
it did show us
it did increase demand on
the website online forms and all of that
but i think it goes back down to kind of
making sure that there were other
options available
um and that you know
i know there were grants available and
uh you know devon county were doing
things like that
so yeah
there is an issue but i think that what
this kind of tries to do is say actually
we've got to improve we've got to kind
of
embrace technology but also not leave
those behind that that on
[Music]
they've been told that if people come in
with specific inquiries and want to be
with it face to face over specific
things they have to send them away and
say you've got to do this digitally
and i would hate that to be the case of
the council i mean if someone comes into
reception even if they can do it
digitally
will they get face-to-face help
investors absolutely absolutely and
that's something that steve and the team
have said from the start you know
reception's there they've got the
customer service that and they're there
to to help out as much as possible
i think that it is kind of a few
different areas where some
want help so that they can do it next
time
online and then there's some that
actually will never
do it and you know
we can kind of do it either way
thank you
john are we moving more into
internet telephones then
we
are looking at options at the moment to
see um for our current telephone system
we're looking at options to see what's
um best and affordable and kind of you
know what works for us
[Music]
well i know i've got one yeah yeah yeah
yeah we are looking at all options at
the moment we had a demo of one um
four weeks ago cool good
that's good
any more questions
[Music]
philippe
um on the front page of the strategy
is there a deadline by which we will
only take digital
applications we've got no deadline at
the moment just to say i took music
today
and there was a gin center there that
when he had a credit card he had to go
100 yards down the field to find a
signal
and i mean there was probably a couple
of thousand people in the field there at
the time and there was no signal no
no anything to communicate and a lot of
rude areas are particularly areas about
themselves and that that is one of our
our issues is the
kind of the
the mobile signal and the
you know the broadband issues and we've
got some kind of
um
i think what it was called
christopher has been dealing with
a couple of the big providers to try to
increase yeah um
wasn't
working at all really for about three
miles yeah
well we are always going to have those
issues in this in this area until
it's you know 100 coverage they'll get
up to 90 something and we'll be
part of that point whatever percent
[Music]
so
anyway
i believe this um report um digital body
phone needs to go to cnr for approval
yeah um so it would be good if you guys
could endorse it so that we could take
it forward
yeah i'm happy to go to do that
proposal
[Music]
yes nobody again
nobody wants to abstain then
okay
all right thank you
yeah thank you
okay next
to my right
and uh by the action list which has
already given you the numbers of
households in in temporary accommodation
um but just to add a little bit to that
so
we have had a massive increase in in
approaches for temporary accommodation
um but that's not necessarily the issue
in itself
um
just to give a bit of background
information as to what the housing
options team do
a lot of their role is triaging roles
trying to maintain tenancies assisting
in social situations assisting with
budgeting to kind of maintain those
tenancies as well
and really our issue is yes we've had
lots more approaches
but
the people are having to remain in
temporary accommodation for far longer
um predominantly because
we can't find permanent properties to
place them into um
and and often
we've got the difficulty that people
just can't afford to maintain the
tendencies so
historically um when approaches were
made in in response to winter is etc
the team would work with those tenants
um to
firstly provide budgeting of advice and
refer them to different agencies and
then
move them into tendencies that were
affordable and were sustainable for them
and the difficulty that we've got in the
moment
is
a lot of these tendencies are not
sustainable um the rent's farting too
much and you know we work with agencies
such as the cab such as encompass and
the messages coming back from them is
exactly the same um it's affordability
um so we've got
a perfect storm at the moment really
we've got the cost of living crisis
we've got an increase in holiday
accommodation airbnb
and we've just got a lack of long-term
affordable tenancies so
what what the team are doing at the
moment is working on a policy which
we're going forward to committee um
shortly
which is looking at subsidizing rents
now we can't do that long term
um
but it will if we can subsidize rents
for a short period
it will hopefully save us on on
temporary accommodation but really and
we need to start feeding back pushing
back to government because
you know from our perspective although
we're happy to assist
for a short period we can't do that
over a long term so yeah
it's not the increases that the problem
it's that that people are staying in
temporary accommodation for far longer
um
than we would want really
um
but the team are doing their best to try
and negotiate with landlords work with
letting agents and obtain what we call
private sector leases or release
properties of private landlords even if
we're having to subsidize a little bit
of the rent in the meantime to to make
accommodation more affordable but it's
really difficult and that's what the
increase on our budget is effectively
people are just there for far longer
when historically we would have them in
some temporary accommodation for a short
period before we moved into some
permanent accommodation that that isn't
what's occurring at the moment so it's a
really difficult time
i'm happy to take any questions
i'll be doing with the pods yeah we're
working on a chair
there's only a few parts it's not going
to be the answer it's going to help
yeah it's not going to be you know it
will help alleviate some contemporary
accommodation costs but again
the difficulty that we've got is once
they're in the pods it's finding them
long-term suitable accommodation any um
progress or finding an industrial
[Music]
so is it
is there an increase in need
or is or is the problem that people
aren't moving on or is it a combination
there is an increase in approaches
but that in itself is it's not an issue
if you can find accommodation so the
team are you know easily able to deal
with the approaches the problem that
they've got is there is nowhere to put
them to so they're in temporary
accommodation for far longer so it's
both really but the message i'm getting
back from the team it's not the increase
it's the properties
[Music]
there is a there is a white paper coming
out in the autumn
or it should be coming out in autumn
from central government whether that's
changed now because of the political
position
but
i'm going to meet him with jeffrey cox
about
three weeks ago
[Music]
about crisis and housing
and the situation is that
we know that airbnb
second homes and all this
are
on the increase
people are getting asked to be evicted
even though they're not in rental rears
or anything because
the owner wants to go down a different
path
and we don't have any
way of stopping that that's if it's his
property or her property or whatever
they can do what they like
our problem is our staff are fabulous
they're working
really hard
but there is no help we don't have any
houses
myself and john
and
councilman we're trying to come up with
ways forward
you know and what we do need
which is really important is the support
of all council the members
to help
alleviate some of the problems
and not fight against us
okay thank you
hello
hang on
peter and then euclid
that's it
that's
you know what sort of
connection communication have we had
with our mp joker cost and you know
making much more fully aware of replies
and
and foreign occasions particular
responses or suggestions
well i've got another meeting with you
coming up in the next few weeks so i'll
bring it to this committee if you want
to bring it back
yeah i think it's fair to say it's not
not just
as well i mean there's lots of areas um
in a similar thing yeah similar
situation
lowering their taxes
anyway mr sean claire
just uh
an observation one of the issues with
the increasing uh rents in the private
sector market
um
when and this is something perhaps i
should have looked into but i haven't
when do lha
rates get reviewed
are they linked to inflation
um and should that be something we are
lobbying the government
about
i
think
and
jay and consultant
no they don't i don't think they've been
reviewed or uplifted for about 10 years
and we haven't tried to lobby on that in
that regard i i guess
political point but on the government
for the government's perspective
increasing lha rates just moves the
expenditure to the dwp so it's still
public expenditure it doesn't solve
necessarily solve that problem it might
solve individual district problems with
a separate accommodation that doesn't
solve a much bigger housing
problem
yeah absolutely not they're not uplifted
by inflation and they haven't been
upgraded i think in 2011 or 2012
was the last time they were changed
all right okay thank you for that can i
just quickly come back because i think
because they haven't been increased
we've got a false picture
of what the value of housing is
and yes i know it's stopping a burden
from local authorities to the dwp and
it's all out of public first however the
the pressures on district councils
who are having to meet this growing
cost
and the fact that it's going to impact
on all sorts of other services that
district health offer
i think perhaps the burden should be
more
shared more equally between the
different departments and the different
uh
pockets of funding of money that the
government has control of
all right
do families in temporary accommodation
have to pay coats and packs
no
sure not in the hospitals
and this is um
the difficulty is um as well as because
they're in temporary accommodation
and that it's for a longer period
and it's sometimes casted their main
residence so sometimes it will
you know we can't alleviate that to be
fair uh
obviously council tax wouldn't wouldn't
be applicable but also sometimes if
they're in so it's better to be in bed
and breakfast and not paying cash for
taxes to be in the other forms of
contemporary accommodation or you are
paying pension tax
i'm not sure because there's other
issues arising because some people
really struggle to be in bed and
breakfast yeah
[Music]
yeah and you know and some people prefer
to be in holiday accommodation for that
reason you know rather than being in one
room so again
i think actually
it kind of
it's an example of how difficult
sometimes um
accommodation can be because you're
managing
lots of other
issues at the same time and quite often
it's
not just for housing and you know if you
could find accommodation that's fine but
there's other issues that you need to
provide
uh support with as well which that you
know the housing team obviously would
we're talking free so it it
could be quite complicated and it's not
a
one-size-fits-all you make an assessment
according to that family thank you
stacy we're investigating accommodation
hospital accommodation in bridge street
still in benefit i understand there was
a possibility of accommodation then
no when we met we are
reviewing accommodation
as a whole
um
you know specifically that area
okay
all right move on oh stephen
just seen
is
um yes on a regular basis basis um
the deputy leader leader and myself
means a regular basis
and you know we've raised all of these
hosting issues uh directly with him
provided to the statistics and but a lot
of it requires government legislation
legislative changes and you know as a
counselor pointed out
um
that that takes time and it needs to go
through
uh a long approach to share and really
[Music]
when
we do the council tax eighteen whatever
it goes up it's like they don't know
where do you
value
those properties i mean in the last
two years
the values of properties in the west
country
of rocky
i only know that because i sold my house
last year
and i sold it it was a band the property
but the amount i got for it
i'm
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
uh instigated uh revaluation of the
council tax property funds or values so
they still based on the 1993 prices yeah
when council tax was introduced that's
the central
[Music]
this is the last one
i think
[Music]
anyway
we'll move on
forward plan
see what we've got on board for the next
meeting
um
anybody else want to
have something put on that meeting
oh no
okay then that's been added to me and
john to find out let's find things out
john
um
okay i'm moving forward to the november
meeting we've got qbr2
and
what while you are away this time before
the 20th of september just have a thing
to see if if you would like something
for
the forward plan
you know and
you know we
just i mean john just don't want to keep
putting the things under we think we
need we need you we need your support as
well okay so just think about that all
right please
um anyway
that's it
i believe
uh
exclusion of the public so everybody can
go from there
and we've been born